[Musique]
il était une fois un gentilhomme qui
épousa en secondes noces une femme la
plus hot n est la plus fière conduit
jamais vu ainsi commence l'histoire de
cendrillon de charles perrault
un conte réadapter depuis 20 ans par la
célèbre compagnie des ballets de monte
carlo
un ballet néoclassique chorégraphié par
jean christophe maillot et la base de
son travail toujours du classique c'est
sûr pointe pour les mais c'est beaucoup
c'est très moderne c'est quelque chose
qui est très différent de ce qu'on
connaît habituellement et c'est ça qui
fait la force des palais saint
christophe
c'est la cinquième fois que la compagnie
monégasque vient présenter ses balais
sur la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
durant deux heures une cinquantaine de
danseuses et danseurs font revivre la
célèbre histoire sur une musique de
prokofiev
sur scène tout senti vibrer rêve un
conte de fées qui propose également une
réflexion sur le souvenir des personnes
disparues
il ya toujours cependant chez jean
christophe maillot de d'avoir deux
personnages comme ça qui raconte une
histoire est effectivement la maman de
cendrillon qu'on connaît tous dans
l'histoire qui est décédé dès le début
du spectacle
et à chaque fois il ya une référence et
là on verra quand même la maman il la
ramène à d'autres à d'autres choses dans
le spectacle qui sont assez inattendu
autre différence avec le conte original
il n'y a pas de pantoufle de verre dans
cette version à la place les pieds nus
de cendrillon sous trempé dans un banc
de paillettes
un détail vo lu par le chorégraphe pour
lui le pied de la danseuse évidemment
c'est quelque chose de fondamental sur
la silhouette sur le l'histoire même
d'une danseuse et le fait de la plongée
dans une danse des temps des paillettes
et de magnifier la la le pied c'est
c'est cendrillon fait le cloud ou de
l'idée du vue du ballet un pied sans
tillon qui saura séduire le prince et le
public
un ballet où l'émotion mais aussi les
sourires sont au rendez vous et qui se
termine par cette phrase bien connue
ils vécurent heureux
[Musique]